we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this may be
one of the craziest calls that we've
ever received buckle up folks hey prick
'less why don't you grow up here if you
had a pair why don't you go back to
Venezuela right away kit here go back
there and my 14 year old daughter come
and kick your bony ass right right I
guess that's it well listen I don't it's
possible that your 14 year old daughter
is very very strong and could kick my
ass I don't know that I just haven't met
her I'm not sure about that now I've
never been to Venezuela and I've
completely condemned the Chavez's Maduro
regime we just have a new report out
about the number of deaths at the hands
of the Venezuelan military Venezuela is
not a place I've ever been to it is
certainly not a place I'm going to
anytime soon so go back to Venezuela
seems like a real question mark we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about no protest zones we will
talk about the real dog human age
multiplier and we're also going to talk
about Michael Cohen spotted at a
Manhattan restaurant allegations
swirling about whether he needs to be
sent back to prison because of that all
of those stories and more on the bonus
show remember that next Tuesday is the
third David Pakman show chess tournament
and our big July one day membership
special get on the newsletter at david
pakman.com to get notified about both of
those exciting events